Denzel Washington is back as the
equalizer in the first sequel that the
award-winning actor has ever done he
returns to the role of Robert McCall
delivering vigilante justice throughout
America the equalizer too follows the
tone of its predecessor in expert
fashion and delivers upon many levels
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the film's ending as well as my thoughts
on the franchise there will be heavy
spoilers for the entire movie so if you
haven't seen it I suggest you turn it
off now if you want to go in unspoiled
with that out the way
I'm definition and I ruin the movie so
you don't have to now working for lyft
and on-demand American taxi service
Robert McCall is able to interact with
the general public and help out the
unfortunate with help from his friend
Susan Plummer he aids a Holocaust
survivor a trouble youth named miles and
more during the film his ally Susan is
called to investigate an apparent
murder-suicide with her partner Dave
York however this is a trap and she is
killed in an ambush by assailants Robert
attempts to get to the bottom of this
and when he gives a ride to a man that
he discovers is an assailant he murders
him and takes his phone which is bound
to put a dent in your driver score
anyway
tracking her death back to York himself
he discovers his old friend has been
betrayed by the people that she trusted
most this sets off a chain of events
that puts McCall and his ward miles in
extreme danger it's revealed that
because of McCall's apparent death the
remaining members of his team had been
fired and were forced to work as
freelance assassin I don't know why they
didn't just become lyft drivers like
everyone else but there you go anyway
because of this Susan became a target
because she would have suspected that
the event in Brussels was from her own
colleagues and eventually she traced
this back to York back in the present
the remaining team members capture miles
and hold him hostage at McCord seaside
hometown McCord dispatches them an
expert fashion before working his way up
to a sniper's nest where York has been
situated
luckily York has worse aim than a
stormtrooper so it's enabled to kill
McCall before he reaches him and in a
dis is spot a moment for cos stabs York
and throws him over the edge where he
plummets
his death back in Massachusetts Susan's
information that she gave McCall helps
to reunite him with his long-lost sister
miles returns to school and focuses on
his art and McCall having moved back
into his old house looks outward calmly
towards the sea the equalizer as a
franchise very clearly has a strong
theme of family whilst McCall's blood
relatives are few and far between in
both films he takes a troubled youth
under his wing and tries to guide them
on the right path he is a surrogate
father in a way but one that is hoping
to carry on his legacy of creating a
person that looks out for those in need
where the police and government have
failed him miles is clearly his Robin
for lack of a better term and McCall
takes pride in watching him benefit
society rather than be a detriment to it
it's great to learn by the film's end
that he has discovered his long-lost
sister and hopefully this will heal a
character in some way for the inevitable
third film though it'll probably end up
that it'll be about his sister getting
shot or something or kidnapped and he's
go go out and stab more people with like
pencils and stationery and stuff and I
just get scared every time the guy looks
at his watch unto another theme McCall
is also a man that has gone through a
journey of losing and finding a purpose
in the first film when he returned back
to a mundane life he tried to convince
himself that he was content before
eventually giving in to his inner demons
when realizing that he was allowing evil
to triumph when he failed to act not
only does this time to the famous
Winston Churchill quote but it is also
mirrored in the quote by Mark Twain
which precedes the first film that quote
is the two most important days of your
life or the day you were born and the
day you find out why this clearly
highlights that McCall needed a reason
to live and he is happy with having a
job below his skill set as long as he is
able to express himself in other means
that serve a purpose it's a fascinating
look at the psychology of a hero and the
equalizer to carries on this aesthetic
in a thrilling way whilst the plot
outcome is rather predictable
Denzel still gives a subtle and
charismatic performance that feels fit
for the franchise though both films
received mixed reviews I'd urge any fans
of the first to go and see it because
not only does the action in this rival
that film but it also carries on its
strong sense of family
there's a definite heart to this movie
so what did you think of the equalizer -
did you enjoy the film or do you agree
with the critics giving it bad reviews
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the ending of Hotel Artemis
and how that movie acts as a metaphor
for healthcare so make sure you check
that out next thanks again for taking
the time to watch this video
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time